there's such an incredible opportunity
there really is guys like all of this
craziness i know it feels crazy and all
the gender stuff and the race stuff and
the media stuff like it's a lot but what
it really also leads us to is that
there's huge opportunity here right it
really is the truth so how are
republicans
or conservatives or just relatively sane
people disaffected liberals how are they
going to save this thing uh well uh elon
musk and you know i often talk about
elon musk because of the twitter thing
but he's right in the center of things i
think in many ways not only because of
his pedigree and and the work that he
does and starlink and tesla
and the boring company and all of that
stuff but because i think he represents
a certain shifting of things he
represents a sort of gen x guy who gets
technology who's not particularly
political but he's become political
someone who's mostly a liberal his whole
life but is now starting to move to say
a more i would say like a post-liberal
thing something like that uh so he had
an interesting tweet two days ago uh
that i want to read to you uh he was
responding to somebody else and he said
trump would be 82 at the end of term
which is too old to be chief executive
of anything let alone the united states
of america if desantis runs against
biden in 2024 then desantis desantis
will win easily he doesn't even need to
campaign now i put out a little twitter
thread uh responding to elon that really
caught fire yesterday and i think it
gets to the heart of what's going on
here and i want to show it to you and
and i would love to hear your thoughts
on this and i know the locals community
uh is talking about it and it's blowing
up sort of across uh across platforms
right now so i quote tweeted him i said
the problem is that biden isn't running
meaning isn't running again he served
his purpose as for trump he has to
decide whether he wants to be king maker
or go for gold in a system which will
never allow him to have it either way
elon is paving the way for cowardly libs
to vote desantis which is good
i continued in a follow-up tweet elon
musk said that he felt trump was a bull
in a china shop and that's true but
there is no metaphor of a panther in a
china shop who slyly lets himself in and
knocks off a few selective items i made
that point to eric weinstein in 2017 and
then there's eric referring to my
comment on that and i think i've got one
more tweet here my hope is that trump
and desantis will work it out privately
there is a huge opportunity to fix the
country right now and there are very few
voters who can actually be swayed but
the non-insane libs bill maher barry
weiss joe rogan could probably move a
lot of people to desantis my guess is
that the mar weiss holly weird crowd
will go down with the damn ship but
rogan must types will go to desantis the
latter is a way bigger group of people
regardless the question still remains
what does trump really want so the
reason i wanted to read this to you
because it's not it it sort of caught
fire online but i think i think i'm
getting to the heart of it and it's it's
why i end up talking about elon musk so
often bill maher so often the ex-lib so
often and all that because if you think
about the election this way or you just
think about america this way
the most people at this point the huge
swath of people have made their mind up
so let's say let's if we're to believe
that 81 million people voted for joe
biden and 75 million voted for trump and
let's not factor in a certain amount of
people die you get a certain amount of
new voters okay let's say those are
roughly what the numbers are right well
how many people that voted for trump out
of those 75 million are going to look at
what's happened in this country and be
like i'm either voting for biden who is
not going to run biden's obviously not
running and he may my guess is he
doesn't make it to the end of the four
years but how many of them are going to
be like i'm voting for biden or whatever
whoever's following up by it and be it
kamala harris or anyone else that they
throw in there gavin news i'm like boy
the policies of the democrats have
really been good over these years the
high tax stuff the locking us in our
house stuff the inflation stuff all
these things by the democrats have been
good there's almost no argument that
anyone who voted trump or is a
conservative or a republican would be
like oh that thing is better now there
is an argument obviously that people who
just had trump derangement syndrome and
just could not get there on trump or
have completely legitimate reasons not
to like trump or whatever it might be
that they might go boy after four years
of biden and the dems and big government
and big taxes and lockdowns and coveted
and done that i'm just going to vote the
other way i actually i've started waking
up a little bit
and you know i care more about states
rights and i want lower taxes there's
definitely an argument that people could
move that way okay so
that's one piece of this but the other
piece of this is if you take those two
groups right and let's say the bulk of
those people aren't going to move who
who are the people that could move right
now well it's basically the non-woke
liberals that's why i reference those
people that's why i talk about the bill
mars and the rogans uh often because
it's the people who should at this point
fully get it those are the only people
and they're just representatives of
people right so they're just avatars in
this equation but it's it's you watching
this or it's your brother or cousin or
friends or co-workers
these these people who always thought
they were liberal their whole lives who
may be old-school liberals i wrote a
book about it
who must now come around i think that's
the only voting bloc in america right
now that there's actual fluidity to
where they actually might say hey i've
had enough of the democrat party and i'm
going to move so that's why i think it's
so so uh
important to talk about because
those are the people that can move it if
you only go to the base all the time if
you only talk about the base then you're
not going to move a lot of people i
would say all that couched in it's why
the desantis thing makes sense all of
the people who had the trump arrangement
stuff it's like well they didn't you
know it wasn't necessarily the policies
people recom remember that the the
country was in good shape the economy
was doing well and all of those things
so it's like desantis he's fought the
machine he fights the media it's all the
stuff that joe scarborough was making
fun of him for and the only reason joe
scarborough is making fun of him is
because he knows he's actually
accomplishing things
but he has the policy we know he knows
how to staff properly um and he doesn't
have all the baggage that trump had but
all of that being said
uh trump has to decide what he wants to
do and that really is the x factor in
this entire thing right that is the one
piece of this that's floating in the
ether that until trump officially says
he's going to do it or maybe trump's
going to wait to the midterm see that
the republicans are going to crush it
see that desantis obliterates the
opponents there are basically no
opponents here in florida and wins this
tremendously or hugely as he would say
and then he's like you know what i will
support the guy and i'll go out there
and i'll campaign for him and everything
else so that's kind of that's kind of
where we're at so again you could to
wrap this whole thing up it's like
liberals if you just look at it they
used to think that abortion was safe
legal and rare that was the same thing
and now it's basically pregnancy centers
equate to al qaeda so if you're a sane
liberal if you're a saint liberal where
are you going to go where are you going
to go well it's on you